a very bright and talented little girl
words from Stella Lily School the latest
victim to a viral infection impacting
the nation in Belfast the five-year-old
was struck down with strep a it's left
to school in disbelief and her family
suffering unbearable pain
but children with colds flu and this
infection isn't uncommon at this time of
year the increased levels of sickness
though is and it's causing concern
particularly at older hay Hospital its
emergency department is the busiest it's
ever been having our busiest winter ever
I think our colleagues around the
country are seeing seeing that from all
the doctors and nurses everywhere so we
were already really busy and I think
since
um over the last couple of weeks I think
since we've been hearing a lot more
about group a strep there's been a lot
more concern about children who might
have it across the UK the number of
children with invasive group a strep is
four times higher than normal what is
usually a mild infection is now in many
cases causing serious harm so today the
government suggested medicinal supports
for schools with outbreaks as an option
what the UK health and Security Agency
are doing is they're working closely
with the schools involved and giving
very specific advice to those schools
which may involve a use of penicillin
and so on all we've got left is probably
about four tubs of the penicillin what's
a mass rollout of penicillin is
something one Pharmacy director says
would be near impossible there's no
drugs there's today we haven't been able
to get any penicillin in stock at all
and we have at least seven different
suppliers that we can turn to and none
of them stock it so then when we hear
stories about possibly giving
antibiotics to to all children in
schools it just shows how out of touch
the Department of Health is
but it's not just an issue for zeeshan
the national Pharmacy Association today
revealed lines of antibiotics used to
treat strep a infected children are
temporarily unavailable there is real
concern over the spread of the infection
across the Northwest here cases of
scarlet fever caused by the bacteria
which leads to strep a are the highest
in the country
and the front line for this infection is
the classroom this Primary School in
Cheshire today received updated guidance
from government but because of a rise of
sickness since October they've already
taken precautions so today that's 90 for
us which is significantly lower than it
has been at all this year so that's
around 40 children froze off with those
kind of symptoms that are missing out on
on their lessons covid-19 dominated our
lives for almost three years and it's
easy to forget the other infectious
diseases that are still causing problems
but despite scientists prior knowledge
strepe remains a worry for parents
across the UK and having the resource to
manage it is now a great concern into
man Rasheed Sky News Manchester